become that you use to kill people yes
this thing I'm gonna used to kill people
in this minute Morrison and how often
would you kill people like every day
kill people for money yes for money and
how much do you know may get paid like
for the big bosses will kill the big
bosses is about 50,000 and kill the
soldiers about 20,000 so how easy is it
to find someone like you if I wanted to
get someone killed
[ __ ] every second guy a organi about who
won't be there long to get someone like
me and how much planning does it take oh
not for me not much but how much time
you have to play but I give you a like a
week as much as a week before we could
you do it in less time and this time if
I see you any time during the Te'o
tonight I've got the connect must kill
you because you're gonna kill me you see
me and do you have a shortage of bullets
or do you find you've got enough
ammunition you can get ammunition from
it you guys would get me by various
people and you know what would happen to
you if you were caught yes
you're not worried about that yeah we're
not actually worried I was able you know
we all kind of come out against and what
about the the conscience of actually
killing someone taking away someone's
life it's not dead out for me in it
because it's what I'm loving like I do
it's for money and I must look after my
family so it's not that hard for me to
kill someone you don't feel anything I
don't know any I did all because he's
not gonna feel any gets on me if you
kill me and how do you kill them I mean
do you just walk up to them how do you
do yes you know we just go then I do my
team shooting the Chasen from net the
main parts of the body how many bullets
would you use to do that I'll use all my
bullets but I'll keep three and even the
first time you kill someone you didn't
feel anything no because the first time
I kill someone before I kill him he shot
me so I didn't feel immediately to of
killing it is there any job that you
turned down
no what I do isn't there's no job right
then down here so if someone asks you to
kill a woman or a child would you think
about that yeah I'll think about that
but then I have to kill you I'm asking
here